there is a growing testing crisis across
the country
people who need tests can't get them
in bolton this couple are told they
can't come into a testing center
without an appointment you just have to
keep on trying
this is the town with the uk's highest
rate of infection
and there is frustration we've been
trying for days
to get online to to have the test when
you ring game into the number
they say oh there's a recorded message
which says that
you're not going to be able to book a
test she's told
to try the town hall and sent packing
bolton is already under a local lockdown
but new cases are still rising
if bolton were a country you'd have to
spend
two weeks self-isolating after leaving
here
in fact the infection rate in this town
is almost
10 times higher than the rate that would
put a country
on the quarantine list despite that
testing is patchy across the country
this test center worker from the
midlands
says it's not working over the last two
days of testing saturday and sunday
we probably only tested less than 20
people on each day
where we have a capacity of over 200
people were presenting
sometimes with children with symptoms
and they were more frustrated than
uh worried because their children were
being kept out of school and they wanted
to be able to get a test in order
to get them back into school and we
weren't able to help them because we'd
been instructed to only
accept people who'd got a valid qr code
back in bolton we caught up with mrs
hadjiali at the town hall
he said that they were giving out the
home testing kits
yesterday so maybe i could get hold of
one today
her security worker husband has been
told a colleague tested positive
and he can't work until he's had a test
eventually
she's told there is no test till
saturday
catastrophe it's a pass the council
accepts it's not ideal the advice at the
moment
is to please bear with us please try um
please continue to try the national
portal we understand that there are
going to be more slots released onto
that portal
and that bolton is a priority area for
that release
the department of health told us the
test and trace system
is working but it's seeing a significant
demand
for tests thank you very much bye the
[ __ ] ali's
can only go home and wait like
countless others who need to know if
they have the virus
or not gerard tubbs sky news bolton